bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 4 mars
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 78 tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
le département des yvelines a présenté
son plan pour les collèges d'ici 2026 15
établissements seront construits hors
construit sur le territoire
l'objectif est avant tout écologique
pour ses sites deuxième poste le plus
énergivore dans l'empreinte
environnementale de la collectivité et
2020 a vu l'émergence de la crise
sanitaire du coc vide 19 l'épidémie a eu
de nombreuses conséquences et notamment
sur l'emploi quel est le bilan de
l'année dans la région et quelle est la
situation actuellement interview avec la
directrice ile-de-france de pôle emploi
et puis reportage au sein du chantier du
multiplexe à plaisir neuf salles de
cinéma le composeront il sera prêt pour
la fin mars au sein du nouveau centre
commercial de la ville ouvert l'été
dernier le premier ministre jean castex
qui vient de prendre la parole pour une
conférence de presse sur la situation
sanitaire nous le rappelle dans un
contexte tendu en france plus de 27
mille nouveaux cas de contamination
recensés hier sur le territoire et les
yvelines sont placés parmi les vingt
départements surveillance renforcée est
d'après les dernières indiscrétions le
territoire comme le reste de
l'ile-de-france ne devraient pas être
concernés par un confinement le week-end
une information qui reste bien sûr au
conditionnel nous devrions en savoir
plus et d'ici quelques minutes et nous
vous ferons le point d'ici la fin de
cette édition
le département a présenté cette semaine
son plan de restructuration des collèges
15 établissements vont être construits
hors construits d'ici 2026 ambitions
affichées réduire de 40% la consommation
énergétique
les détails avec bixente maria
santisteva la fois un dernière
établissements en ciment les nouveaux
bâtiments du collège lycée franco
allemand de buc représente la fin d'un
cycle
un plan de restructuration académique
présenté par le département
nous allons consacrer sur 50 2021 à 2026
525 millions d'euros à la construction
de 15 nouveaux collèges ça ne veut pas
dire que dans ces cinq ans honda
n'annoncera pas l'autre car nous voulons
intensifier ce rythme avec l'idée dont
de bio sourcés ces constructions des
projets écologiques avec des bâtiments
issue d'énergies renouvelables ou de
matériaux de récupération
une diminution de la consommation
actuelle des collèges de 40% et une
faible empreinte carbone
en ce moment on dure de la commune il ya
une espèce d'inquiétude sur l'évolution
climatique
elle est très prégnante notamment chez
les lycéens et les collégiens et je
crois que c'est leur envoyer un beau
message de dire on vous met dans des
conditions qui seront celles du futur
les futurs effectifs ont été étudiées
pour répondre aux besoins des communes
tout en accueillant les élèves dans les
meilleures conditions
la proposition qui fait par le
département de construire plutôt des
collèges qui sera aux alentours de 5 6
ans de manière
râle c'est pour moi la bonne dimension
pour un collège on essaie de coller à la
réalité
par exemple aujourd'hui sur
aubergenville c'est un collège neuf
cents ils sont six ans donc il n'ya pas
de prévisions
nationale ou locale de dénichant un peu
plus importantes on l'a dit muet à 700
parmi les dernières incertitudes des
discussions autour d'un nouveau collège
à trappes entre le département et la
municipalité
deux autres établissements seront
restructurés sur l'espace saint quentin
en yvelines
lamarre au sol à coignières et le
collège albert einstein de magny les
hameaux
tous devraient être achevés d'ici 2026
dans l'actualité la mise en examen de
sidi el haimer le premier adjoint de
mantes la jolie est visé par une enquête
pour subordination de témoin il est
accusé d'avoir joué un rôle dans la
sphère du racket des commerçants du
marché du val fourré révélé en 2019
cinq hommes ont déjà été mises en examen
pour avoir mis en oeuvre un système de
racket auprès des commerçants de ce
marché qui est l'un des plus importants
en ile-de-france et les enquêteurs
estiment à 2 millions d'euros les
montants frauduleux empochés par les
placiers du marché en dix ans après une
garde à vue où il a nié les faits qui
lui sont reprochés par la police
judiciaire de versailles signé les
moeurs a été remise en liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire en ce début du mois
de mars nous avons souhaité faire un
point sur la situation de l'emploi en
ile-de-france avec la crise sanitaire
muée en crise économique quelle est la
situation actuelle en ile de france et
surtout quel est le bilan de l'année
2020 eléonore si nokia rencontrer la
nouvelle directrice régionale de pôle
emploi patrick jacques de dixmude pour
les moyens techniques ou sam au sein du
bâtiment de la direction régionale
ile-de-france de pôle emploi et nous
sommes avec vous nadine crinier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la directrice du coup
du pôle emploi ile-de-france première
question quelle est la situation de
l'emploi et du chômage dans la région
alors l'emploi dans la région a connu
une forte dégradation main et le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi augmenté
puisqu'il y à 750 me plus de 750 mille
personnes qui recherchent un emploi à
temps plein et qui sont immédiatement
disponibles
c'est une hausse sur un an de cent mille
personnes donc c'est important et c'est
dû principalement à l'arrêt de
l'activité restauration hébergement
tourisme prix globalement mais aussi une
activité internationale qui est beaucoup
freiné et on peut le retrouver en impact
sur l'industrie industrie lourd mais
l'agroalimentaire aussi et tout ça hein
pas particulièrement
région en termes de pourcentage cela
représente combien d'augmentation
finalement entre 2019 et 2020 alors
entre 2019 et 2020 ce sont plus presque
9 % de demandeurs d'emploi en plus et
une baisse des recrutements des
entreprises de près de 30% alors même
s'il y a eu une amélioration au
troisième trimestre le quatrième a
marqué aussi une stabilité pas de
progression pas de dégradation mais en
tout cas une situation qui du coup a
vraiment empirer avec les deux premier
trimestre et qui ne s'est pas récupéré
sur la fin d'année
donc ça c'est la situation dans la
région ile de france
qu'en est-il dans le département des
yvelines plus précisément alors les
yvelines résiste un petit peu mieux si
je veux prend par exemple le taux de
chômage le taux de chômage des yvelines
arrêté au 3ème trimestre 2009 1 est à
7,2 au niveau de l'île de france
il est à 8,3 donc voyez un taux de
chômage un peu plus faible mais qui est
aussi le fruit de l'histoire
historiquement les yvelines avaient un
taux de chômage plus bas
l'autre point des caractéristiques de
des yvelines
c'est qu'on a plutôt des jeunes avec un
niveau d'études élevé plutôt une
dominante de bac plus trois mais qui
vivent quand même avec difficulté les
restrictions en du marché du travail
moins d'opportunités et puis aussi les
cadres qui sont si parmi les personnes
les plus touchées
donc même si le taux de chômage s'est
détériorée même s'il n'est pas le plus
haut de la région il ya malgré tout des
populations nouvelles qui rentre au
chômage donc ça c'est un élément
important
et puis parmi les secteurs qui ont le
plus baissé au delà des secteurs que
j'ai cités sur la région vous avez
l'industrie qui dans le département des
yvelines a b c a vu ses effectifs
salariés de baisser de près de 20%
donc ça c'est une particularité des
yvelines donc avec une industrie qui est
beaucoup en baisse par rapport au niveau
régional qui lui est plutôt stable sur
l'industrie baisse assez conséquente en
effet est-ce que c'est dû à la crise
sanitaire et du coup quel est l'impact
de la crise sanitaire sur l'emploi en
ile-de-france alors l'impact de la crise
sanitaire c'est bien l'art est certains
secteurs un pratiquement et puis des
secteurs émergents mais qui ne viennent
pas compenser les pertes
donc ça c'est le premier point donc on
voit une augmentation des recrutements
dans le commerce plutôt un commerce de
proximité
on voit aussi une augmentation des
recrutements dans la santé pas
uniquement dans les hôpitaux aussi dans
les établissements accueillant des
personnes dans les ehpad dans les
établissements médico-sociaux le secteur
qui recrute plus en ce moment et ça a
été près de 96 minutes diffusée en 2020
c'est le bâtiment qui vraiment a repris
alors il est aidé aussi par le plan de
relance avec des aides aux collectivités
des aides au niveau 2 de l'habitat pour
un habitat plus écologique est donc tout
ça a plus les grands chantiers 1 le
grand paris les chantiers djo
prochainement tout ça amène beaucoup de
besoins et sont des secteurs où les
personnes ne s'oriente pas naturellement
donc le travail d'orientation vers les
secteurs est extrêmement important santé
bâtiment le numérique aussi qui
recrutent
on voit bien aussi que dans cette
période le commerce digitalisées donc
son essor y compris pour des petites
structures bas amène à des besoins de
développeurs et puis après il ya aussi
tout un volet sécurité des systèmes
d'information fortement utilisés durant
cette crise qui amène aussi à avoir des
besoins d'ingénieur en sécurité
informatique
alors vous avez parlé des secteurs qui
recrutent est quelle mesure a pris pôle
emploi également pour pour gérer la
crise la situation sanitaire pour aider
les bénéficiaires alors des mesures de
proximité ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'un demandeur d'emploi durant de
confinement durant cette période de
forte distanciation sociale on veille à
le contacter pour faire un point avec
lui alors c'est à la fois une relation
professionnelle mais aussi de visant à
s'assurer qu'il n'est pas trop isolé 1
c'est vrai que dans la période parfois
on intervient aussi pour faire le relais
avec d'autres structures pour
accompagner les personnes sur un champ
plus sociale voire plus
morales aussi parfois et puis vis-à-vis
des entreprises nous notre rôle c'est
d'aller en proximité des employeurs
voyez à des secteurs pour lesquels les
recrutements se sont arrêtés et c'était
plutôt ceux avec lesquels on travaille
est donc pour nous l'enjeu c'est
vraiment d'aller vers les secteurs qui
recrutent nous faire connaître pour
capter ces besoins et amener des
demandeurs d'emploi qui n'avait pas
identifiées a priori ces métiers et bien
à engager une formation ou à s'adapter
aux postes de travail proposé dernière
question très rapidement comment vous
est accordée avec vos partenaires comme
la région ile-de-france l'état pour
justement gérer cette crise on a
vraiment partagé avec l'état et le
conseil régional la nécessité
d'augmenter le nombre de personnes
formées
c'est vraiment un enjeu parce que le
marché du travail évolue on l'a vu sur
des nouveaux métiers qui recrutent en
plus grand nombre et malgré tout malgré
l'augmentation du chômage on a toujours
des difficultés à recruter
donc il faut continuer à former et à
grande échelle à la fois pour les
besoins de demain parce que conforme
c'est pas tout de suite mais aussi pour
la suite
élever le niveau des qualifications pour
que les gens puissent encore mieux
s'adapter aux évolutions technologiques
et au besoin aussi de la société donc ça
c'est le premier enjeu avec les missions
locales
on a aussi un travail de proximité
d'alliance de travail si je puis dire
puisque nous accompagnons des jeunes de
façon spécifique avec des conseillers
spécialisés jeunes entre guillemets et
le but c'est de pouvoir les aider aussi
financièrement et les collaborateurs des
missions locales ont cette compétence
sociale et nous aident à déterminer des
aides complémentaires
en plus de notre accompagnement
professionnel merci nadine crinier
d'avoir accepté cette interview et je
rappelle que vous êtes la directrice de
pôle emploi ile de france
toujours en matière d'emploi à saint
quentin en yvelines les personnes qui se
questionnent sur leur parcours
professionnel peuvent s'adresser à la
cité des métiers avec la crise sanitaire
à la dure
adapter une partie de son offre en
distance yale conseil ateliers de
formation ou informations ils sont
dispensés
interview express collectées par bixente
mais rien senti steban c'est comme une
boîte à outils où les personnes peuvent
venir ben bas à prendre approfondir et
comme c'est ouvert et qui a toujours des
professionnels qui sont présents
je peux venir tous les jours si je veux
je peux avoir quelqu'un qui va m'aider à
construire avant cv ou à répondre à une
question qui va répondre à une question
tous les métiers sont impactés en fait
par part du coup le numérique et par
rapport au contexte c'est sûr que
certains secteurs d'activité comme la
restauration par exemple il ya des gens
qui se disent bon bah je
il faut que j'anticipe il faut que je
change on a eu aussi des personnels de
santé qui sont une ouvreur pour changer
il ya déjà le wiki qui démarra cursus et
qui se posent des questions donc on peut
changer de voie et construire un nouveau
projet on s'est dit qu'on allait faire
une montée une après midi spécial
orientation quand les jeunes du coup les
parents vont pouvoir venir avec leur
avec leurs jeunes rencontrer des
professionnels
donc on a cinq professionnels qui seront
là c'est le 17 mars
mercredi 17 mars de 14h à 17h
cette signature ce jeudi matin à paris
jacqueline gourault ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
valérie pécresse présidente de la région
ile de france et marc guillaume préfet
de l'île de france se sont réunis pour
signer l'accord de relance état région
l'objectif apporter une réponse rapide
et massive aux conséquences de la crise
sanitaire 13,8 milliards d'euros vont
être investis en 2021 et 2022 consacrée
à la transition écologique au
développement des transports notamment
le prolongement du rer e
l'automatisation de certaines lignes
comme la ligne du rer b également les
aménagements cyclables la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments est mais aussi
un soutien apporté aux entreprises et à
l'accès aux soins de tous les élections
régionales approchent elle devrait se
dérouler tout comme le scrutin des
départementales les 13 et 20 juin
prochains sur twitter la tête de liste
europe écologie les verts dans les
yvelines est connu il s'agit de
ghislaine sénat elle a été dévoilé sur
twitter mer des vêtements de 2008 à 2020
un conseiller régional depuis 2010 elle
accompagnera donc julien bayou qui
conduit la liste écologique au niveau
francilien d'autres candidats se sont
déclarés en ile de france laurent saint
martin pour la république en marche
jordan bardella avec le rassemblement
national
audrey pulvar avec le parti socialiste
et clémentine autant avec la france
insoumise la présidence sortante valérie
pécresse devrait également être en lice
pour un nouveau mandat mais elle n'a pas
pour l'heure annoncé sa candidature
officiellement
courant février deux centres
hospitaliers français ont subi des
cyberattaques face à l'augmentation du
phénomène
la start-up auxi box implantée à
guyancourt propose ses services
gratuitement aux acteurs du service
public victime elle aussi d'une
cyberattaque la mairie de où il s'est
par exemple rapprocher de cette société
pour en bénéficier
nicolas landry c'était le 29 janvier
dernier les services municipaux 2 où il
victime d'une attaque informatique
directeur des systèmes d'information
externalisés pour la commune thomas
herbert a accompagné la municipalité
face à soeren somewhere une cyber
attaque avec demande de rançon le
prêteur et a pu pénétrer le système
d'information et le réseau à travers une
faille du firewall dus principalement en
fait
l'obsolescence des matériaux et une
mauvaise mise à jour en fait des
différentes versions ça bloque
complètement toutes les applications
métiers d'avis les finances les
ressources humaines mais également tout
ce que j'ai une vive donc le la gestion
d'état civil le cimetière l'aide sociale
la police municipale etc pour remettre
en place le système thomas herbert a
pris contact avec l'entreprise auxi box
situé à guyancourt
il y a quelques semaines cette société
spécialisée dans la cybersécurité a
lancé une offre gratuite destinée aux
administrations publiques une solution
de redémarrage de l'activité après une
attaque
l'idée c'est de leur permettre de
s'équiper maintenant rapidement devoir
prendre décision facile afin de parer à
l'urgence puisque il ya une épidémie
aujourd'hui qui se propage une épidémie
de rands somewhere qui se propage aussi
bien dans les hôpitaux sujet est pris à
bras le corps par les pouvoirs publics
que dans les collectivités territoriales
peut-être société guyancourt toise a
déjà reçu plus d'une centaine de
demandes de la part des administrations
publiques
le sport et du cyclisme la 79e édition
du paris nice débutent ce week-end et
une fois encore cette année la course au
soleil va s'élancer depuis les yvelines
une première étape dimanche au départ et
à l'arrivée de saint cyr l'école 166 km
au travers des communes de versailles
ben ou encore de châteaufort le
lendemain
lundi départ depuis la petite commune et
doivent ils sur mon cyan direction
amilly dans le loiret après 188 km de
parcours qui passera par les villes de
trois-rives en billets
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines attention en
raison du passage de la course cycliste
des restrictions de circulation sont à
prévoir à saint cyr l'école et à
versailles toutes les informations sur
les sites internet des communes qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et direction
plaisir à présent il sera bientôt prêt à
ouvrir le multiplexe du centre
commercial mon grand plaisir sera livré
à la fin du mois le point sur ce
chantier avec eléonore sinoquet environ
1300 fauteuil neuf salles et un grand
groupe de cinéma ugc
voilà ce à quoi devrait ressembler le
nouveau multiplexe de plaisir débuté en
juillet dernier le chantier du nouvel
équipement avance bien et n'a presque
pas subi la crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui toutes les cases iman toutes
les salles sont terminées avec les
écrans de poser les fauteuils il nous
reste encore deux salles où il faut
mettre les fauteuils notamment avec les
fauteuils et adultes et enfants dédié en
même temps maintenant il reste la
peinture duo le montage des caisses
définition on est vraiment rentré dans
la dans la phase de finition du cinéma
le chantier s'est très bien déroulé
malgré tout la conjoncture coe gide et
cetera donc naturellement avec tous les
protocoles de sécurité qu'on a dû mettre
en place pour les ouvriers pour que le
chantier semaine à bien mais tout s'est
bien déroulé et c'est pour ça qu'on est
à peu près dans les temps pour ce futur
cinéma un plaisir installé en plein
coeur du centre commercial mon grand
plaisir
le nouvel établissement viendrait
compléter l'offre culturelle de la
commune l'unique cinéma avait fermé ses
portes en 2008 à plaisir nous n'avons
pas d'autres cinémas on faisait le
cinéma en plein air pendant l'été
puisque avec le département dans le parc
du château on avait ça mais on n'allait
pas d'autres salles de cinéma 9 salles
c'est exactement ce qu'il nous faut mais
je pense qu'on va rayonner bien au delà
plaisir parce qu'on a pas mal de
villages autour de plaisir qui attendent
aussi cette ouverture de cinéma si la
fin du chantier est prévue pour la fin
du mois de mars
rien n'est moins sûr pour l'ouverture
officielle qui dépendra des conditions
sanitaires et avant de vous laisser je
vous le disais en début d'édition le
premier ministre jean castex a pris la
parole il est toujours en train de
s'exprimer pour faire un point sur la
situation sanitaire en france le
contexte est toujours tendue je vous le
rappelle plus de 27 mille nouveaux cas
de contamination
hier en france le premier ministre
annonçait d'ailleurs que parmi ces
nouveaux cas de contamination plus de
60% proviendrait du variant anglais est
les yvelines sont pour rappel place est
aussi parmi les 20 départements en
surveillance renforcée mais pas de
confinement décidé c'est officiel un pas
de confinement décidé pour l'heure pour
le week-end dans les yvelines et dans le
reste de l'ile-de-france en revanche les
centres commerciaux de plus de 10 mille
mètres carrés vont devoir fermer leurs
portes dans les vingt départements qui
sont placés en surveillance renforcée
donc les yvelines en font partie le port
du masque obligatoire dans les zones
urbaines nous relayons nous avons relayé
cette information dans le journal de tv
60,18 le préfet des yvelines a d'ores et
déjà décidé un d'une obligation du port
du masque sur l'ensemble du territoire
yvelinois depuis à quelques jours et
enfin le premier ministre a dit que les
préfets pourraient décider d'éventuelles
restrictions supplémentaires notamment
de réglementer l'accès de certains sites
très fréquentés par le public et aussi
d'interdire certaines manifestations
enfin jean castex a annoncé également
que dans les 20 départements en
surveillance renforcée est la stratégie
de vaccination serait accélérée c'est
une actualité un bien sûr sur laquelle
nous reviendrons dans notre édition de
demain l'émission le 7-8 week-end qui
est présenté par eléonore sinoquet voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]